Let us now speed Hermes the guide, the slayer of Argos, toward O'Gigia Island, so that he can speedily announce your steadfast decision to the nymph of the beautiful braids, that Odysseus, whose mind stands fast, shall make his journey home. For my part, I will embark for Ithaca there to breathe purpose into his son, that I might instill a man's courage within his heart, and to make him call an assembly of the long-haired Ithacans and tell all the suitors to go. Those men who never leave off slaughtering throngs of his sheep and his lumbering twisty-horned cattle. To Sparta, I shall send him and to Sandy Pylos too.
To learn whatever he can of his dear father's journey home. And to help him as well to earn a noble renown among men. So that was Dame Edna Reveridge, playing the goddess Athena. And Athena is talking to her father Zeus, King of the Gods, and this is in the first of the 24 books that constitute Homer's great epic, The Odyssey.
And as we were saying in our first episode, there is something very Australian about the expedition of Odysseus and his men across the Aegean, barbecuing on the beach, drinking unnecessarily, behaving badly, and basically comporting themselves
like Australians on the beaches of the Dardanelles. And so we felt that Australian voices, Russell Crowe in the last episode across between Kylie Monogue and Dame Edna and this one were at the most appropriate. I was imagining Kylie, I have to say. Right.
It turned into Dame Edna. If I shut my eyes, I could imagine Kylie and then I'd open my eyes and see you and it would all go. Yeah, nice. I mean, a lot of people's fantasy, actually. Anyway, the translation there is by Daniel Mendelson, who's on our bonus episode
for Restis History Club members talking about the Odyssey. Of course, we're doing this series is because the film by Christopher Nolan is out this week. It goes on general release on the 17th. And Tom, I know you've gone online, haven't you, to book your tickets because you don't want to miss out. Is that right?
Actually, I went to the preview. Okay. That's just showing off, isn't it? It's just showing off. It's the sort of boastful behavior that you would expect of a Greek hero, I guess. Yeah, it's a key in behavior. And I will regret it when I end up in the underworld. This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's five.
house deposit and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth of the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody's listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to buying their first houses and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may
be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions apply. That's right, it's heating up everyone. The rest is football is on Netflix for the world's biggest tournament and we're officially in the business end. The knockouts are here and don't worry, myself, Alan and Micah are still here every day from New York City, all the debates from the biggest games and a special guest or two for good measure. What a time we're having. Don't miss it.
Twizzlers keep the fun going. Yeah, I know. I just stopped whatever you were listening to to tell you that Twizzlers, keep the fun going. Well, irony isn't my forte, but twisty, chewy, yummy Twizzler sure is. So think of Twizzlers as a little palate cleanser for whatever's queued up, which by the way should be coming very soon. Like any second now. Okay, Twizzlers, time to keep the fun going. So a recap to remind people where we are in the story. In the first episode, we heard how Odysseus, the wiliest, the smartest of all the Greek heroes, fought for 10 years in the Trojan War,
He was the maestro behind the Trojan horse, that he tries to get home with his men and he is blown fatally off course. And Tom remind us of all his adventures and what happened. So loads of mad adventures, one-eyed giants, beautiful sorceresses. He goes to the underworld meets the ghost of his mother and various of his fallen comrades. And he ends up losing all his fleet. He had 12 ships. They end up completely destroyed. And all his men.
He is the only survivor of the entire expedition. and he has been washed up on the mysterious island of Ogigia, ruled by a nymph, the lady Calypso, that radiant goddess. And on Agigia, he has been kept essentially as Calypso's sex slave for seven long years. And every night he would spend with the nymph doing as she commanded. And every day he would weep for Penelope, his beloved wife, his soulmate. And Agigia is described by Homer as being the Omphalos of the sea, the naval of the sea, a place so remote that Plutarch, who was writing in the second century AD, so centuries after Homer wrote it, would place it five days sail west of Britain. So that would make it, what, Newfoundland, I guess? Yeah, I mean, somewhere on the way to Canada anyway.
Yeah, but I think Plutarch. is wrong because in truth, Agigia is a place that transcends geography and in fact, time, because it's meaning in Greek or Gigios, it means primal before the dawn of time. So essentially, Odysseus has passed into a strange dimension where the conventional rules that govern mortals no longer apply. And he has vanished from the world of humans. And Calypso actually means in Greek she who veils, she who conceals. So it's the same route as Apocalypse, which means an unveiling. So Odysseus can't escape partly because she won't let him go, but also I think because it is impossible for him to get out of this kind of strange dimension that she controls and coordinates.
But the reason also why Odysseus can't escape, and people who listen to our first episode may recall this, is because Odysseus very foolishly has offended beside him. who is the god of the sea and he'd done this by blinding his son, the one-eyed giant polyphemus. And so Poseidon, he doesn't necessarily want Odysseus dead. He's perfectly happy to leave him on this kind of island prison with Clipso as the governor.
And as far as Poseidon is concerned, he can just stay there and rot and never get back home. But Odysseus has a powerful protector of his own, doesn't he? And this is the person who we heard voiced by Dame Edna, at the beginning of the episode. So this is another Olympian, and this is Athena. And she likes Odysseus because she sees him as like-minded, because they're both very wise and clever.
Yes, I think she sees something of herself in Odysseus. And so during the Trojan War, she had spoken to him. She'd occasionally appeared to him. Over the course of his adventures, she has not appeared to him or spoken to him because she doesn't want to offend Poseidon. Fortunately, however, as the Odyssey opens, Poseidon is in the land of the Ethiopians who are not to be identified with the people who live in what today we call Ethiopia. Their name means people with burned faces, so people on the edges of the world where the sun is at its brightest.
They're blessed, they're noble, they're the kind of people that God would like to spend time having a holiday with. And so Poseidon is away from Olympus. And so this gives Athena her chance. And as we heard in that passage with which we opened, voiced by Kylie Stroke Dame Edna, Athena has a two-prong strategy. So the first is to get Zeus to send Hermes, the messenger of the gods, to a gigia to order Clipso to set Odysseus free. And secondly, Athena herself will go to Ithaca, Odysseus's home island, and there visit Telemachus, Odysseus's son, and basically kind of encourage him to man up
to stop being so wet. So this is the moment actually where the Odyssey begins, right? Yes. Where the story that we encounter in the book starts with Athena. Yes. Going to see, is it going to see Telemachus? That's the bit that it kicks off with. Is that right? Yes, important for listeners to understand who've not read the book that the epic does not begin with the fall of Troy. It doesn't begin with Odysseus embarking on his adventures. So not basically as we did it in the previous episode.
It begins with this moment, with Athena going down to see Telemachus. And 10 years have passed since the fall of Troy. So 20 years since Odysseus had left Ithaca. And people may remember that when he'd left Ithaca, Telemachus was just a baby. but now he is a young man. But to be fair to Telemachus, I mean, he is facing a very challenging situation because Odysseus, before he'd left for Troy, had told Penelope, and I quote, once you see our son starting to grow out his beard, marry whomever you wish. In other words, if I'm not back by this point, you should assume that I'm dead. And people know this. And so
Odysseus' hall is now crowded with suitors who are slaughtering Odysseus's, um, cattle and sheep and insulting his household. Penelope, she wants to hold out. She's hopeful that Odysseus will come back. She knows her husband. She's confident he'll come back. And so she doesn't want to marry any of these suitors. And so for years, she's been keeping them at bay with, again, a kind of very famous wheeze. It's a kind of, it matches the Trojan horse, her husband's great weas. And what she had done was she said to them, I will marry one. of you, once I have completed weaving a shroud for Laertes, the father of Odysseus. And so she sat at her loom, weaving at it all day.
And then at night, secretly, she would steal down and unpick everything she had done in the day. Right. And so the suit is a thing. This shroud is taking a long time. It's taken about five years. But in the end, the scheme is betrayed by one of Penelope's servant girls, one of her maids. And so the scheme is rumbled. But at this point, Penelope is still holding out.
You know, she doesn't want to give in. And Telemachus also is kind of backing her. But he's just a young man. You know, he hasn't had his father around. He's not kind of trained in the ways of warfare and whiliness and all of that. He's very, very young and inexperienced. And so this is why Athena has decided to visit him, to offer him the kind of advice and encouragement that he hasn't been getting from his father because his father is absent.
She disguises herself, doesn't she, as an old friend of Odysseus, with the excellent name of Mentor. Yes, she's literally his mentor. Yeah. And when Mentor arrives, Telemachus is very courteous, he's very generous, but Telemachus is extremely embarrassed. It's basically this massive kind of, it's basically like a stag party that's got. Yeah, they're all wearing plastic breasts and covering each other with shaving foam naked. Yeah. It's basically weather spoons at Luton Airport, you know, 8 o'clock in the morning.
People are absolutely off their faces already. Like, there's a lot, there's all kinds of bans. So it's miserable for Portolemachus. So Athena cheers him up, first of all, by saying, actually, I think, you know, I think it's okay. I think your dad is alive. And I think he's going to be coming back home soon. And she then says, you should stand up for yourself.
You should show your independence. And you could do this in a couple of ways. So you could summon an assembly of all the people of Ithaca and publicly make a stand in front of them against the suitors. And then when you've done this, that you could go and visit some of Odysseus's old mates, some of, you know, some of his comrades from the Trojan War and find out what they know. And then, to quote Homer, so saying, Athena went off, she of the bright owl eyes, just as a bird will fly off in a flash and into
his heart, she put fierceness and strength. And this fierceness and strength, as we've been saying, is something that hadn't previously been evident in Telemachus. And so the suitors, he holds this public assembly for the Ithacons, as Athena had advised. And the suitors go there and they shout it down. But they are startled that Telemachus has had the initiative and the gumption to call it and a little bit worried about this sudden display of kind of character and independence. And even Penelope is surprised by the way in which her son is suddenly showing a kind of assertiveness. So that's a marker that he's laid down for the suitors. And then he heads off for the mainland.
And again, he does it without telling them what he's doing. He slips away unnoticed. And he heads off to the mainland of Greece, to the Peloponnese. And there he's going to visit two of his father's old comrades in arms. And the first of these is a guy called Nestor, who is the king of Pilos on the west coast of the Peloponnese. And he had been the oldest warrior who'd fought at trial. fabulously ancient and doddery and long white beard and all of that. And unfortunately, Nestor has no idea where Odysseus is, so he's not much use.
But he says it's like he's vanished off the face of the earth. I've heard no rumours about him whatsoever. But he kind of cheers Telemachus up by telling him war stories. You know, Nestor's an old man and so the joke is that this is all he ever does is tell stories about the good old days. But these are stories that feature Odysseus being an absolute legend. I mean, kind of literally. And he tells stories about how brave Odysseus had been, how clever, and how close he had
been to Athena. So Telemachus had seen Menthol turn into a bird and flash off. So it's, you know, cogs in his brain are starting to work thinking maybe Athena is on the scene. And certainly the effect of Nestor and his conversation is to make Telemachus feel proud to be the son of such a man and make him want to be kind of worthy of such a father. And so from Pilos, Telemachus then heads inland to Spartan. where the king is Menelaus, and he is the husband of Helen, whose abduction had led to the entire war. And Helen, when she comes in to join Menelaus and Telemachus in the great feasting hall,
she immediately recognizes him as Odysse's son, because Helen is the daughter of Zeus. She has a kind of witchy quality. She has kind of supernatural powers. And Helen sits with Telemachus, and she tells him a story about Adiscus. how back in the days of the Trojan war, he had infiltrated Troy disguised as an old beggar, and that he had disguised himself so effectively that he'd had himself lashed across his back, like a slave, so that when he came into Troy, people could see these marks, and it would have seemed impossible to the Trojans to think that this could actually have been a great hero.
And Helen boasted to Lemicus, I alone saw through his disguise. And of course, she could have betrayed him, but she truly, chooses not to. And she says, for by then my heart had long since been bent on going back home. And Menelaus then tells a story also about Odysseus, how they've built the Trojan horse and the Greek heroes, the Achaean heroes, have hidden themselves inside the great belly of the horse. And then Helen had come down to them and started calling out in the voices of their wives. So again, this is the kind of the witchy quality of Helen. And it's undermining her claim actually that she was now on the Greek side.
I was about to say she's playing both sides. Yeah, she is playing both sides. Yeah. And the men inside the horse, they hear that what seems to be their wives, they're so homesick, they're so longing for their wives that lots of them want to kind of call out and reply. But Odysseus knows what's going on. He keeps very silent. He keeps them motionless.
He puts his hand over the mouths of those who look as if they're about to call out. And these two stories, the story firstly told by Helen, then by men of the men of the Elias, again, they're illustrating the qualities of Odysseus, how intelligent he is, how bold, how daring, and also how self-disciplined he is. But the most crucial thing that Menelaus tells Telemachus is that he does actually have news of Odysseus. And this is because he had ended up on his journey back from Troy in Egypt. And there he had captured the old man of the sea, he's called Proteus, who is a kind of shepherd of seals. has all kinds of weird supernatural powers, able to change his shape. So that's where the word protean comes from. But Menelaus had captured him and held him despite all this shape-shifting, and finally had got Proteus to reveal to him all kinds of things. And among the things that Proteus had revealed is the fact that Odysseus is alive. And to quote what Proteus had told Menelaus, I saw Odysseus on an island, his eyes brimming over with tears in the halls of the
nymph calypso who is holding him there by compulsion he is not able to return to the land of his fathers so now telemachus knows he is alive so that's where we left adesius last time and we left on the cliffhanger is he ever going to escape from the arms of calypso and i'm happy to say that the answer is yes and this is down to athena isn't it because basically we said that she does two things she goes to telemachus but she also goes to see zeus yes her father father and Athena is Zeus's favorite daughter. Poseidon is absent. And so Athena is basically kind of sassing around Olympus trying to sort things out for Odysseus and hassling her father. And finally Zeus gives in to her and sends Hermes, the messenger of the gods, down from the
summit of Olympus all the way to the island of Agigia, this naval of the sea. And when Hermes arrives there, he tells Clipso, you've got to let Odysseus go. And she had a clip. Clip, So he has a massive strope about it. And Hermes says, do not provoke Zeus to anger. You know, do not make him angry. And so very reluctantly, Calypso permits Odysseus to build a boat. And she gives him provisions and says, okay, you can go. But before he goes, she makes him a great offer.
And she offers him the gift of immortality if he will stay with her. And listeners may remember that in the previous episode, we talked about how Odysseus had met with Achilles. the great hero who is now just a kind of a shadow in the underworld. And Achilles had basically said, you know, life is so much better than death that you should embrace any opportunity you can to perpetuate it. So this is a massive, massive offer. But Odysseus turns it down. And it's one of the great eulogies in ancient literature to the joys and the comforts of marital love.
It has to be said there aren't actually that many. And it begins, it doesn't sound like a unity to his wife, it has to be said, but it kind of pivots. So, Odysseus says to Clipsoe, look at my wise Penelope. She falls far short of you, your beauty, your stature. But she is mortal, after all. She's not a goddess, so you'd expect that. You, you never age or die. Nevertheless, I long, I pine in all my days to travel home and see the dawn of my return. So he would rather live with Penelope and die than live with Clipso. and live forever. And it's a kind of moving moment, I think. Not many wives who would welcome that tribute to themselves that begins with them saying, she falls far short of you. Anyway, Odysseus sets off from a gigia,
and well, these things always end up going one way, don't they? But actually, at first, it's a bit like a Titanic. Everyone talks about the bit where it went wrong, but no one talks about the first couple of days. So in this case, the first 17 days of the voyage or a triumph, but then on the 18th day of the voyage Poseidon is on his way back from the land of the Ethiopians
and he sees Odysseus below him doesn't he? So Poseidon is in the sky Yeah and it's just this tiny little dot but he's a god I mean of course he can recognise him he's furious about it and so he strikes the sea with his trident churns it up
pulverises Odysseus' raft all the gifts that he's been given by Calypso all his provisions even his clothes he loses them all So he's now kind of naked, literally naked in the salty, boiling sea, almost drowns. There's an island ahead. He's almost smashed onto the rocks by the waves.
And in fact, had it not been for Athena, who personally intervenes to save him, he would have been killed. But as it is, with the assistance of the goddess, he is able to crawl himself up onto a sandy beach. And he totters up into a nearby wood. and there's kind of leaves scattered around everywhere. So he hides himself under the leaves and understandably collapses, falls completely asleep and sleeps for who knows how long. But then abruptly, he is woken by the sound of a ball splashing into a pond and the sound of girls shouting and giggling. And obviously, when you've been through a series of adventures that involve giants devouring your men or spanishing, spear on you in harbours or whatever. I mean, these are these are the kind of things that you want to hear.
He's still dreading the worst because he's gone through so many terrible experiences. But he thinks, well, maybe, you know, they're just girls. Maybe it's all right. And also he's desperately hungry. He's desperately thirsty. And so he picks up a kind of a branch with leaves on, a bit like Adam in the Garden of Eden. He uses it to conceal his nakedness. And he steps out and emerges from the wood. And in a clearing, it's the most domestic scene imaginable. It is a group of girls doing the laundry. And they look around and see what seems to be this awful kind of briny pervert, start naked, who stepped out from the woods, like a kind of flasher.
And they understandably scream and run away. But one of the girls does stay and bravely stands her ground. And Odysseus addresses her from a distance. He doesn't want to frighten her. And he talks to her with absolutely perfectly pitch flattery. So he compares her to Artemis, the daughter of mighty Zeus. And he narrates his ordeals and then he appeals to her for help. And finally, and I love this moment, and I think it's clearly betraying his own longing for Penelope.
He's, you know, he's seeing this girl and he's thinking of his own family. And he wishes her a happy marriage. And he says, for there's nothing as powerful. powerful or as great as when a husband and wife united by oneness of mind in their thinking, keep their home together, a great bane to their enemies, a blessing to their friends, and their renown is on everyone's lips. And Sadie and I had that at our wedding. Oh, nice.
Which we had in a church. But important to emphasize, this is very much not a Christian ideal of marriage. This is an ideal of marriage in a world in which it is households, rather than individuals who are being joined. And so to be a bane of one's enemies, a blessing to one's friends, this is a dream that's particularly suited to royal couples because obviously the whole health of a city of a kingdom
can depend on it. And as it turns out, Odysse's words are perfectly suited to the young girl that he has addressed them to because the girl that he is addressing is not an ogress, not a witch, not a ghost, but a mortal princess. So the name of this princess is Norsekeia. She's the daughter we told of Alkinos the great-hearted. And in his hands like the power and might of the Feitians.
And who are these people? So the Feysians, to the degree that the Odyssey offers one, is a kind of a vision of an ideal society. So Norsekaia's parents, the king and queen of the fysians, Alkinnos, the king, they are wise and generous. They have no idea who Odysseus is, but they greet him with great kindness and hospitality. So this kind of this great quality of xenia, which is so important to the Greeks, welcoming strangers with hospitality. They have kind of perfect microclimate. So their fruit, their vines, their vegetables are always in season. There's no winter.
And they have kind of incredible 1950s science fiction style labor-saving devices. So kind of robotic guard dogs made of gold and silver. And they have ships powered by what sounds a little light AI. Wow. Kind of that's free thinking. They can think faster than any human being. and these ships can travel at a completely miraculous speed. It can kind of travel the length of the Mediterranean.
Self-sailing ships. Self-sailing ships, yeah. So, again, it's this familiar thing that we were talking about in the first episode, that you have the fantastical element of an island, but then also there are points of similarity with actual islands that exist in the Mediterranean. Right. And so to Homer's original audience, the location and the description of the kind of physical geography of Faisha,
made it seem like it was the island of Kukaira, which is now Kofu. And we did a bonus with Alex Preston about this for club members going to listen to that. And as we've said, Nauticaea, you know, this princess who's doing the laundry and playing, you know, with the ball with her friends and stuff. I mean, this is a world away from the island of Clipso or Circe or whatever. And most amazingly of all, and it's one of the great kind of postmodern moments in the Odyssey. There is a bard at Alkinuas's court who seems like Homer himself. So Homer traditionally is said to be blind and this guy is blind. And it may well be that that description is what gives rise to the legend that Homer was blind.
And he's inspired by the muses, as Homer was thought to be. And he reduces grown men to tears with the power and the pathos of his epic singing. And this blind poet sings to the court at Fascia. and among the men at this course, of course, is Odysseus himself. And the bard is singing about the Trojan War and about the feats of arms that Odysseus himself had performed at Troy. And Odysseus weeps to hear them. You know, it's noticed.
And so, you know, Alkinna says, stranger, why do you weep? And Odysseus finally reveals who he is. And it is this which prompts him to tell the story of his adventures. So the Lotus Eaters and the Cyclops and everything. So this is the narrative that we told in episode one. So it's brilliantly, brilliantly meta. You were saying that it's kind of postmodern book. And of course, there's loads of stories within stories, aren't there in the Odyssey?
That's how it works. So you can see what it would appeal to a filmmaker. Yeah. You know, flashbacks and things like that. Yes. And I guess particularly one like Christopher Nolan, who loves all these kind of games with time and so on. And so it is, you know, he tells his story.
And at the end, everyone is silent, held absolutely spellbound. all through the shadowy palace. And Alkinuos is the king, is so moved that he says, well, we've got to get you back to your home. We've got to get you back to Ithaca. And so at last, 20 years have gone by, but now Odysseus is ready to go home. And Alkinous loads one of these kind of free sailing AI powered ships with all kinds of gifts. And Odysseus boards it. and he curls up and he falls asleep and the ship speeds across the seas, miraculous power.
The morning star rises. And as the morning star rises, this ship reaches Ithaca at last. And the fysian crew lift the still sleeping Odysseus out of the ship. And they place him and all the gifts that Alcinois had given him on a beach under an olive tree. and then we're told they themselves went back speeding homewards. And so it is in the most unglamorous, the most kind of anticlimactic manner possible that Odysseus returns to Ithaca. And as had been foretold, he has done so not on his own ship, but on someone else's ship. And he has arrived there alone, but he is at home at last.
But is this the end of his troubles? Spoiler alert, it is not. His troubles are only just beginning. We'll find out why after the break. This episode is brought to you by Hamilton the musical. Tom, when we think of America's founding fathers, we think of dusty portraits, grim-faced men with terrible teeth, and of course unpaid tax bills, don't we?
That's right, but what we don't see is the struggle, the resentment, the euphoria, the love, the rapping, all in the name of American independence. 250 years ago. That's what we loved, isn't it, about Lynn Manuel Miranda's award-winning musical Hamilton, which we went to see with our team just the other day. It brought the story of those turbulent years to life beyond the walls of a museum from the room where it happened.
It's an incredible depiction of the life and legacy of Alexander Hamilton, who was George Washington's right-hand man, an incredibly politically significant figure. It is an absolute cultural phenomenon, and you can experience it right now at London's Victoria Palace Theatre. Book tickets today at Hamilton Musical.com forward slash London. This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows.
Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. Zeus whose shield is thunder, standing by me always in every combat mission, no maneuver of mine slips by you. Now again, give me your best support, Athena, comrade. So that was Odysseus talking to Athena. Now that's actually not from the Odyssey. It's from the Iliad as translated by Robert Fagels. So it perfectly illustrates how close the two of them had been in the Trojan War, how they'd been secretly communicating with each other. She'd spoken to him, for example, in the
that passage that we were just quoting, she speaks to him through the kind of cry of a heron. But here's the twist. Then during the voyage, for the 10 years of the voyage, that communication basically died. She kept silent because she didn't want to offend her fellow Olympian Poseidon. But now at last Tom, Athena is back. She absolutely is. And to have her on the scene for Odysseus is obviously brilliant news. But remember, at this point, he doesn't know where he is.
So just to give people a reminder where we are at the story. Odysse's wife, Penelope, is in his palace. There are 108 suitors by this point, all kind of competing for her hand in marriage. And they are all of them kind of insolent, violent, and, in fact, murderous. And I say murderous because, people may remember that Telemachus had gone off on his voyage to see Nesta and Menelaus on the mainland of Greece. He is now sailing back from mainland Greece to Ithaca. And the plan of the suitors, now that they've rumbled where he's gone, is to ambush and kill him at sea
before he can reach Ithaca. So that's bad news for Telemachus. Meanwhile, Odysseus, as we described at the end of the previous half, he has been left asleep beneath an olive tree on Ithaca. And when he wakes up, he, you know, you said, he has no idea where he is. Yeah. And so he fears the worst. He thinks, oh, no, this is another terrible trick. Poseidon is still kind of intervening to make my life hell. And so he trudges mournfully, we're told along the shore of the endlessly clamouring sea, kind of wondering, where am I? And then ahead of him, he sees a very handsome young shepherd lad. And so he hails the shepherd lad and says, where am I? And the shepherd boy answers, sir, you are in Ithaca. So you would think at this
news that Odysseus would, you know, I mean, he'd kind of explode with joy. But he's Odysseus. He doesn't. He disguises his delight and instead invokes the cunning in his heart and tells this absolute kind of cock and bull story about how he's actually a fugitive from Crete. I mean, it's kind of making things up just for the joy of making things up. The shepherd boy kind of listens to this story and then starts laughing. It's not a shepherd's boy's laugh. It's a woman's laugh. And she starts stroking him with her hand and materializes before him as this beautiful, towering woman. And it is, of course, Athena. And she says to him, a man would have to be crafty, a sly old fox to outdo all your tricks. She loves it. She can't get enough of a dicistice's a trick. she thinks it's great. So she basically explains to Odysseus the situation. This is what's going on
with all the suitors and this is how you're going to deal with it. And she has a plan, doesn't she? So she's basically going to disguise him. She's going to turn him into a beggar so that you will look vile in the eyes of all, the suitors and your wife as well as your child. Yes. And so she turns him into this kind of hideous old beggar. And then when she's done that, she says, go to the heart of the local swineherd Yumaeus, who Odysseus remembers from when he was in Ithaca 20 years before. And this is a man who is still loyal to Odysseus and to his house, so Telemachus and Penelope. And meanwhile, Athena tells Odysseus, I am going to go and I'm going to escort Telemachus safely back so that the suitors plan to murder him is foiled. And all of this is what duly comes to pass. So Odysseus, he's
disguised as a beggar. He goes to Eumaeus's hut. Yumaeus treats him with great hospitality, with great generosity. He's just a humble swineherd, but again, he's kind of model of zania of kind of hospitality. It soon becomes clear to Odysseus that Eumaeus is utterly devoted to Odysseus's memory. He remains completely loyal to him. But despite this, Odysseus is Odysseus, so he doesn't reveal himself. Again, he comes up with some mad story, says he's a Cretan. And there's a bit of a joke here, I think, because in antiquity, the Cretan were always viewed as notorious liars. So Odysseus is kind of signaling that it's a lie. And he has this kind of great story saying that he'd served as a mercenary in Egypt, and then he'd
had a run-in with Phoenician slave traders. And I think the thing that's interesting about this is that it clearly reflects the world in which Homer is writing this epic down rather than the age in which Odysseus is meant to have missed, because going to serve in Egypt as a mercenary or having run-ins with Phoenician slavers, this is much more appropriate. to the 8th or 7th centuries BC than to the, you know, to the bronze age. So it's like the register has kind of slipped. Yes, slightly.
Yeah. And it may be that that's the whole point, you know, that this is a lie. You know, again, this is kind of quite postmodern that Odysseus is telling a lie. Homer is telling a lie. There's a kind of, you know, hall of mirrors there. Odysseus also having come up with this kind of, again, this cock and bull story to Emaeus, he tells Eumaeus, I have news. of your master, your missing master, Odysseus, he is on his way home. But Eumaeus, who's believed
everything else that Odysseus has told him, all of which is a lie. This one thing which is the truth, Eumaeus does not believe it. And he tells Odysseus, the storm winds have snatched all his renown away. So Eumaeus basically thinks he is at the bottom of the sea. He is drowned and dead. Now, Telemachus has gone away and the suitors are waiting to ambush him. But Athenaeus, saves him, doesn't she, and brings him back safe and sound to Ithaca, he goes straight to Eumaeus, to Eumaeus's hut, but Emaeus is out, and now comes one of your favourite moments in the whole story. It's one of the great, great moments in Homer, because now is the meeting between the father and the son. So Athena, you know, she's disguised Odysseus as a beggar, all that goes. She restores
him to his full stature and nobility, gives him a kind of little touch of stuff. so he looks even better than normal. And at first, Telemachus just cannot believe that this father, who, you know, he doesn't remember at all. He'd just been a baby when Odysseus left. He can't believe that Odysseus is back. But then, to quote Homer, he twined around his noble father, wailed as the tears pulled down, and a desperate longing for weeping welled up in both of them.
And so father and son, they embrace lots of sobbing. but there's a time when the sobbing has to stop because there is a lot of suitor killing to be done and this is now absolutely Odysseus's purpose and at first when he tells Telemachus this, Telemachus is very skeptical because remember there are 108 suitors and there's only the two of them but Odysse says, look, I'm a hero. I've killed a lot of people and also we have Athenaeer on our side and on top of that I am the cleverest man in the world and I have have a cunning plan. So here is my plan. I am going to infiltrate the palace in my brilliant disguise as a beggar. Your role Telemachus, when the moment comes, is to remove all the weapons
that are hanging in the hall, and which the suitors might otherwise be able to use. You've got to remove them and conceal them. And what you should do is to leave just two swords, two spears, two shields, and that will be for our use. And then if we are armed, this. suitors aren't, we should be able to deal with them. I am confident of our ability to pull this off. So the excitement mounts are approaching the endgame now, the climax of the Odyssey. We'll start the very next morning, Tom. Take us into the story. Okay. The suitors have come back from their failed attempt to ambush Telemachus. Athena had managed to trick and fool them. And so now they've come back to Odysseus's palace and people may be wondering, well, you know, why don't they just kill Telemachus in
Odysseus' halls? Well, the reason for that is that they don't want to risk the anger of the gods, or indeed the people of Ithaca, by publicly murdering Odysse's son. And so that means that when Telemachus comes back from Eumaes's heart, after to meeting with his father, they leave him alone. You know, they kind of eye him warily, but they don't attack him. And so Telemachus is able to go to Penelope to talk with his mother and to tell her what he has learnt. in Sparta that Odysseus is alive. He does not tell her that Odysseus is back and that he has seen his father. So he proving himself a slight chip off the old block there. He also introduces her to a guy called Theo Clemenus, who is a wandering seer that he has brought back with him from Sparta. So it's the kind of thing you'd bring back from your Greek holiday. You'd pick up a wandering seer, I think, say, look what I've got. And Thaiclaminas also has amazing news. And Thericloenus says to Penelope, Odysseus, even now, back in the land of his father's already settled or on the move,
learning of these wicked deeds is here. And he is sowing seeds of evil for all the suitors. But Penelope doesn't believe him, thinks that this cannot be true. She's been told so many lies over the years. She just can't bring herself to believe this news. But of course, it is true, because all the while, in his beggars disguise, Odysseus is approaching the gates of his palace. And on the way, he has a run-in with his old goat herd, a guy called Melantius. And Melantius is very much not like Emaeus. Melantius feels no loyalty to Odysseus, shows no courtesy to strangers. And so when he sees this old beggar, he gives him a kick and not realizing as he does say that, of course, he's kicking his own master. So that is something for Odysseus to bear in mind, the fact that his goat herd has kicked him.
Will he wreck an awful vengeance? Well, time will tell. And now he comes up to the gates of his palace. And as he approaches them, he sees on the side of the road lying on a dung heap riddled with flies, an old scabby dog. And this dog is Argos, his beloved hunting dog, the dog that he had raised by hand as a puppy before he left for Troy. And as he walks past in his disguise as a beggar, nobody else recognizing him. Argos does recognize him, raises his head, pricks up his ears, wags his tail. And then, quote Homer, his fate, black death, took him in its grip.
the moment he saw Odysseus after 20 years had passed. So the single most tragic moment in the Greek history of relationships between pet owners and their pets. Very sad moment indeed, very famous. Yeah. So now, in his beggars garb, Odysseus, after 20 years away, goes into his palace. And Melantius, the goat her, mad from Melanthius now and who's got teamed up with the sister Melantho who is a concubine of one of the suitors they mock him don't they because they just think he's a beggar he's just a
yeah you know a tramp or whatever yeah they've got no time for him and also they got no time for penelope either neither of them loyal to Penelope in the slightest yeah a dish is disguised as a beggar is led into the hall and one of the suitors a guy called antinuous robert patterson i think in the Christopher Dolan film. He throws a footstool at Odysseus. And to be fair to the other suitors, they do think that this is poor behavior. They think, you know, you really shouldn't just throw stools at beggars. That will bring bad luck.
The gods will be angry. And so they make sure to give the old beggar some bread and meat and to kind of welcome him. And so the beggar is kind of sat at the side of the hall, the disguised Odysseus. And Penelope comes down and she notices him. And she thinks, he has the look of someone who might have wandered in far lands. Maybe he has news of my husband. And so that evening, she summons him for a private conversation. She doesn't recognize him.
But there's something about him that makes Penelope kind of confess to him all her grief, all her longing for her husband, and all her dread that she simply won't be able to keep these suitors at bay for much longer. And the disguised Odysseus replies to this by saying, well, I have news of your missing husband. I've seen him. And he gives a description of Odysseus that is so convincing that Penelope is persuaded that he's telling the truth. And she starts weeping the thought that perhaps Odysseus, her husband, really is out there. And the beggar says, you are right to have hope. Trust me, Odysseus is on his way. And Penelope is so happy about this that she says, look, you know, you're covered in scabs and dirt. Let's have you washed. And so she summons an elderly attendant in the palace, Euryclae, who had once been the nurse of Odysseus, so had knew Odysseus very well and intimately. Penelope orders Euriclaea to wash the feet of this old beggar. And Euraclair does so. And she sees that there is a scar on the thigh of this beggar.
And she recognizes it because this was a scar that Odysseus had got as a young man when he'd been out hunting bore with his grandfather. And Euryclare, because she had often washed Odysseus, of course, she now recognizes it. And she says to him, truly, you are Odysseus, dear child. And Odysseus said, be silent. Do not reveal who I am. puts his hand over her mouth, almost throttles her with his desperation not to have his secret betrayed. And so Euriclair keeps the secret. And he then goes back to his conversation with Penelope. And Penelope says, look, I've got a plan, best way that I can think of to keep the suitors at bay.
What I'm going to do, the next day, I am going to go down to them. And Odysseus, my missing husband, he has this great bow, which only he had ever been able to string. And I'm going to tell the suitors, whichever of you can string the bow and then shoot an arrow through 12 double-headed axes lined up in a row in the hall. was a favorite party trick of Odysseus is, if one of you can do that, then you will become my husband. And Odysseus hears this plan and he says, yeah, that is brilliant. That is a tremendous plan. Because of course, it completely dovetails with what he wants to do. And I think there is an ambiguity in Homer. There is the possibility that maybe Penelope has recognized him. Yeah. But she is a woman of tricks like he is. They're kind of start.
to play this game where they're each telling tool stories to the other, not quite revealing. I mean, it's not absolutely stated, but I think part of the fascination of the scene is that that is clearly a possibility. The two of them now retire to bed. So Penelope, we're told, cried for her dear husband Odysseus until sweet sleep was poured onto her eyelids by Athena of the bright owl eyes. Meanwhile, Odysseus has gone down. He's lying in the hall and he can hear various slave girls in the household slipping out to have sex with the suitors who've taken them as concubines. And he's furious about this. He's anxious about how he's going to deal with the suitors. You know, is he taking on too much? And so he can't sleep. But then Athena appears to him, reassures him. And as she had
granted Penelope the gift of sleep, so Athena grants Odysseus the gift of sleep. And both husband and wife get the rest they're going to need for what is going to be a very, very momentous day. All right. So the fateful day has dawned at last. This is the day when there's going to be this contest with the bow and the axe for the hand of Penelope. The suitors are in great form.
They're feasting. They're fighting with each other. They're throwing bones at the beggar, who is, of course, Odysseus. Yeah. But Odysseus and Telemachus are getting ready for what they know will be a decisive moment. So Temaikas has taken weapons out of the hall, hasn't he?
And they have Eumaeus on hand, who's the one guy that they can trust. There's also another cowherd, I think. Is that right? Yeah, so Eumaeus is the pig herd, the swineherd. And this guy is the cowherd filotius. He's also loyal. And so Odysseus hasn't yet revealed who he is to either of these guys, but he knows that he can trust them.
So they're on hand. And then we've got the wandering seer who Telemachus had brought back from his holiday to Sparta with him. And he pops up and the suit is all having a great time and then he tells them what's coming. Blood is spattered all over the walls and the beautiful rafters. The entry is filled with ghosts, the courtyard filled with them too, which isn't at all the kind of thing that you want if you're having a great time. So the hour arrives. Penelope enters the hall and she is holding. the great bow and quiver of Odysseus and behind her a train of her women holding the 12 axes made of bronze and iron. Penelope announces to the suitors her decision that whoever can
string the bow and shoot an arrow through the axe heads will become her husband. And Telemachus then sets the axes in a line along the hall and the suitors all step forward. And the suitors all step forward in turn to try and string the bow, all 108 of them, and not one of them has the strength to string the bow. Meanwhile, as the suitors are doing this, Odysseus has taken Eumaeus, the loyal swineherd, and Philotius, the loyal cowherd, outside, and at last now, he reveals his true identity. And they think this is brilliant, you know, they fall to their knees, absolutely delighted, sobbing with joy. And he gives them specific tasks. You mayas is to bring him the bow when the time comes, and Philotius is to lock the gates of the hall
so that no one can escape or summon help. Inside the hall, the suitors have all been trying to string this massive bow and failing. And so Odysseus goes back inside the hall and he makes a suggestion. He says, well, why do we have a go tomorrow? At dawn, the God will grant victory to whomesoever he wishes. And in the meanwhile, he says, while we're waiting, because you're all obviously now at a bit of a loose end, why don't I have a try? You'll find it. Entertaining, watching me, a stooped old beggar having a go. Where's the harm? And at this, the suitors explode in indignation. And Antinuous, who, you know, the guy who'd chucked the stool at him right at the beginning, so the most boorish of all the suitors, he rounds on Odysseus disguised as the beggar
with insults. But first Penelope and then Telemachus, tell Antinous, show some manners. You are in our hall. And Telemachus tells Penelope, go to your rooms. So again, you know, he's definitely manned up. I think it's fair to say. And then he gives a secret nod to Eumaeus. This is the signal to, you know, we're about to go. And so Eumaeus, as he'd been instructed to go, goes over, picks up the bow and gives it to Odysseus. And Odysseus, tests the bow, he scans it, Homer says that he almost caresses it, and then abruptly to the absolute stupefaction of the watching suitors, he strings it. And he plucks the string to test his pitch. And as he does so, we're told, Zeus sends a flash of lightning from the clear blue sky
overhead. And then Odysseus takes an arrow and he knocks it and he draws and he draws and he lets fly and the arrow passes through all 12 of the axe heads. Yes, the bronze-weighted shaft sailed straight through them. And at this point, Telemachus reaches for his sword and spear and Odysseus strips off his rags, and he aims an arrow at Antinuas the worst behaved of all the suitors, and he lets fly. And Antinous, who is obliviously lifting a great golden goblet to his lips as all this is happening, is struck directly in the throat and blood spurts out in a great jet. It's a very cinematic description from Homer. And at the spectacle of this is complete pandemonium.
And the suitors all think that the beggar must have done it by accident. I mean, surely this is the only explanation. But no, because now comes the moment when Odysseus announces himself to the whole. You dogs, you never imagine that I would make my way home from the country. of the Trojans, look how you've wasted my house, how you've forced yourselves upon the slave women in bed, how while I was still alive, but out of sight, you courted my wife. And the slaughter begins and it is terrible and it is total. But there is a chance for the suitors, isn't there? Because you'd mentioned earlier this goat herd Melanthius, who would identify himself as an
absolute villain by kicking Odysseus when he was on his way in. And this, actually slips out of the hall and starts to bring them weapons and armour, doesn't he? He does. But fortunately for Odysseus, he's rumbled by Yemeyas and Philotius. And they truss him up and they lift him up to the roof beams and they leave him hanging there. And this portends nothing good for Melanthius. And meanwhile, the slaughter is continuing in the hall. And Athena has turned up for the fun. And she's not there to help Odysseus, but basically to goad him on and tell him to kill even faster. And she materialises first as mentor. So this old friend of Odysseus, which was the form that she'd appeared to Telemachus at the beginning of this episode. And then she turns into a swallow
and she perches on the great smoke-blackened roof beam of the hall. And this is something that she loves doing. She loves taking on the form of a bird, and particularly when there are spectacles of bloodshed. So in the Iliad she had disguised herself as a vulture and there are descriptions of her kind of shivering with delight at the spectacle of blood being spilled. And spectacles of blood being spilled is absolutely what she gets now in the hall of Odysseus. So tremendous violence, tremendous slaughter, all the suitors end up dead. And the metaphor that Homer uses is that of fish being dragged onto a beach in nets and speared. And there's an echo there of what had happened to Odysseus's men in the harbour of the Lestrogonians, where the Lestrogonians had gone and speared all his
men. So the suitors are wiped out, but they are not the only victims of Odysseus's terrible vengeance. Because he, when the slaughter is done, he demands to know of Euryclae, his old nurse, which of the servant girls have been sleeping with the suitors? And Euraclera replies, well, there were 12 of them. So it's a bit like post-Vici France. You know, they are female collaborators, horizontal. That's exactly the analogy I thought of. And their fate is horrible, isn't it?
Yes. So they are told to carry out the corpses of the suitors, among them they're dead lovers. And then to clean the hall, the tables, the benches. Meanwhile, Telemachus has strung a ship's cable from a pillar to a beam and from this cable, the maids are hanged. To quote Homer, a horrible description, just as when some thrushes with slender wings or some doves go crashing into a snare. And we're told that as they are throttled, the girls' feet twitch.
And then Homer says, but not for very long. I wonder if Tom Holland's going to be doing this in the film, because he's Telemachus, isn't he? I mean, it's genuinely interesting to see whether the slaughter of the servant girls included. I can't imagine Matt Damon doing it, but who knows? It'll always be so interesting to see whether Melanthius features as a character in the Nolan film, because he is given a particularly horrible punishment, so his nose and ears are sliced off, his genitals are cut off and fed to dogs, and his hands and feet are amputated. And Homer does not specify whether he dies of this mutilations, or whether he's just left to eke out of hideous.
living as a beggar. Yeah. What would one prefer? I don't know. There is a lot of brutality in this world. But Euryklaea, I mean, she thinks it's all brilliant. She couldn't be happier, the spectacle of all this slaughter and bloodshed and castration. And in fact, she's almost laughing for joy as she rushes up to tell her mistress, Penelope, what has been going on.
But Penelope still can't quite believe it. Or does she? Is she still playing games? And she comes downstairs and she gazes at Odysseus. And Homer says that she is torn by uncertainty. Sometimes as she stared at him, she seemed to see his face, but sometimes she failed to recognize him dressed in vile rags. And Telemachus can't believe this. How can his mother possibly doubt that she is gazing at her husband, Telemachus's father? But Penelope says, look, if he truly is Odysseus, we will know each other in our own ways. For we, you know, we have signs. We have. We have. have secrets that are known only to the two of us. And Odysseus smiles at this. And again, I think there's this sense that they're playing the kind of games that perhaps they played before he left for Troy. And so he says, run me a bath. And Penelope obeys and a bath is run for him. And then when
he steps out from the bath, we're told that Athena poured great beauty upon his head. But Penelope, She's still not welcoming him back as her husband. And Odysseus says, your heart is made of iron. You are the hardest of women. But Penelope says, I don't care. I'm not going to be taken for a fool. And she says to Eureclair, go and move the bed out of our bridal chamber, the chamber that Odysseus, my husband, built with his own.
own hands. And when a dish is hears this, he explodes. And he says, what do you mean? This bed can't be moved because when I made it myself, I fashioned one of the four boasts out of a living olive tree. And I had then built the bed chamber around this living olive tree, around this bed that I've made out of it, adorning it within lays of gold and silver and ivory. So in other words, the only way that the the bed could be moved is if someone had cut the living trunk of the tree. And this is something known only to Odysseus, only to Penelope. And so when he says this at last, Penelope's knees give way and her heart as well. And she embraces him and she kisses him and she is struck in her joy by the last of the poem's great similes. And it reverses what had happened because now it is
Penelope who is being compared to the sailor lost at sea. She, Homer says, is like a shipwrecked sailor crusted in brine who at last treads on dry land after escaping from disaster. And the great moment of husband and wife being joined together after all these adventures, all these many, many years of absence, at last it arrives. And they retire to bed and Athena holds back the coming of the dawn so that they can enjoy the ultimate reunion. And the amazing thing is, again, it's another kind of postmodern kind of meta aspect of the poem that they have time because Athena has pushed the dawn back for the pair of them to catch up on what the other has been doing. And so Odysseus basically tells the story of his adventures, so essentially what we covered
in episode one. And Penelope tells Odysseus what she's been like. to, so basically the outline of this episode. So in other words, the first people to narrate the action, the story of the Odyssey are Odysseus and Penelope themselves. I'm the first people to hear it. And the first people to hear it, although obviously not the last. So the appeal of the Odyssey, Tom, what do you think it boils down to? Because it's obviously the product of a very specific time and place, and yet it's proved so enduring and so influential on Western literary culture and more generally. I think it's exactly that fusion. I think it's the fact that it has gods, it features famous monsters.
Speaking for myself, I loved that as a child. That was the quality that I loved. But also, to be honest, I loved the violence of it and the murderous quality of Odysseus as well as the cunning aspect of him. People, I think, enjoy that in stories. There's a savagery to it that's often lost in children's versions, I think. A cruelty. But also, I think the basic plot of it is so adaptable.
It can be retold in so many ways, and it has been retold in lots of ways. I mean, there are elements of it in Virgil's poem The Aeneid. That in turn influences Dante, who describes Odysseus. After he has returned to Ithaca, he ends up bored, and he sets sail for his last great voyage to the ends of the world. And that is then reworked by Tennyson in the 19th century in his great poem Ulysses. And I think it's a perfect way to end this because it describes a hero who will never come to rest, who will always be embarking on fresh adventures. And you can see that now with the Christopher Nolan film.
There was the Ray Fines film as well, which describes his homecoming. And that is just one of a kind of endless number of reworking that continue to, to be made in film, in fiction, in poetry. So let's end it with Tennyson's Ulysses Odysseus, saying how he is going to leave on one last final voyage. Though much has taken, much abides, and though we are not now that strength which in old days moved earth and heaven, that to which we are, we are,
one equal temper of heroic hearts, made weak by time and fate, but strong in will, to strive, to seek, to find, and not to yield. Well, thank you, Tennyson. And thank you, Tom, for what's been an epic journey, an odyssey, dare I say? Literally so. Through this most influential of all great stories.
So next week, we will be somewhere very different. We will be in late 1880s, Fandescik, Vienna for the Murder Suicide Mystery of Myeling. And Restis History Club members can get both of those episodes on Monday. You won't have to wait. And by the way, we are running our summer sale. So if you want to join the Restis History Club, this is the moment. For a limited time only, you can get 20% off an annual membership using the code summer 26. And that offer is valid until August the 31st.
So on that, Bombshell, thank you very much. Tom, thank you, everybody. And goodbye. Goodbye. If you want a $3,000 a month payday for life, what would you feel free to do? Maybe take a long weekend, every weekend, or try a bunch of new hobbies. Would you feel free to upgrade and listen ad-free? Don't worry, we get it.
Every $20 ticket could win you $3,000 a month for life and supports life-saving cancer research at the Princess Margaret. Feel free to buy your payday for life ticket today. Raffle number 155-214. Please play responsibly. Hello there. It's Al Murray. here and James Holland there, hosts of the Second World War Pod, we have ways of making you talk. Alan and I have been on The Rest Is History a few times now, talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic.
If you've enjoyed their recent topics on 20th century history, then we have good news for you. Yes, that's right, Jim. We have our own show, all about the fascinating history of World War II. Every Tuesday and Thursday, WW2 Pod, we have ways of making you talk, discusses the fascinating people, amazing innovations and terrible tragedies of this most pivotal period in human history. Yeah, and the bottom line is, other history has absolutely nothing on this. This past year alone, we've done series on visionary US presidents
like FDR and Truman, HMS Hood v Bismarck, and Japan's Road to War. We've also explored daring night raids behind enemy lines like Bruneval and the nerve-wracking Atlantic convoys. And right now, we're doing the truly Titanic Operation Barbarossa,
the Nazi German invasion of the Soviet Union in the summer of 1941. So now is a great time to subscribe and get into the action. Search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts. That's we have ways wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mary Beard. And I'm Josephine Quinn. At the rest is fest this September, we're putting on a show that can only be described
as an iconoclastic romp through the ancient world. We're talking about leaders behaving badly. Emperors putting their horses in charge. cities built by asylum seekers and empires getting their comeuppance. There will be some proper myth busting. But we'll also be asking why these myths matter, even when we know they're wrong. So if you love your ancient history and you're free on September 6th, get your ticket now and join us at London's South Bank Centre. Tickets are on sale now.
Just visit southbankcentre.com.com.uk. That's southbank centre.combe.com.uk. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.